all right boredom is feared by everyone
from adults in the workplace to kids who
are home on their summer break but a
recent Academy of Management study finds
boredom can lead to increased activity
Apple co-founder Steve Jobs said boredom
allows one to indulge in curiosity and
author junior art Okun created the
Hobbit when he was a professor and was
bored of grading papers so it is time to
put our phones down and give our minds a
chance to wander psychiatrist dr. su
varma joins us at the table good morning
dr. Varma I aspire to boredom I should
say I love the idea of boredom because
it feels I mean why does it lead to
creativity yes so it's interesting our
boredom is our brains way of searching
for an interesting stimulating activity
and if we can't find it in the external
environment we are going to create it
and I think of creativity as a space
between boredom on one hand which is a
lack of stimulation and anxiety which
might be over stimulation and in fact
that this is such an important trait
there was a study done in 2010 an IBM
study looking at 1,500 CEOs from across
the world and they found that creativity
was the number one important leadership
quality and my fear is that now we live
in a work warrior culture and we're
promoting productivity at the expense of
creativity and we're finding that as IQs
are increasing creativity quotients are
actually decreasing boredom has such a
negative connotation I mean we using the
right word for what you're talking about
here no we're not using the right word
boredom is absolutely necessary you know
there's a part of our brain called the
default mode Network and even though
it's not actively engaged when we're
doing like goal-directed activities the
it's it's on all the time like you ever
wake up from sleep and say AHA like I
know the solution to my problem we think
our brains are off our brains are never
off you know show me the off button
isn't that rest or relaxation you know
some activities are intentional right so
those would not be considered boredom so
if somebody says like I'm doing a yoga
class and I'm gonna get fresh ideas not
necessarily the case boredom is what
happens you know you might be literally
doing something routine repetitive take
the same walk home swimming laps and
you'll find that there we need both
convergent thinking and divergent
thinking divergent thinking allows us
all possibilities and that can only
happen during routine activities if
you're on public transportation in this
country if you're on line in this
country 9 out of 10 people are like this
on their phone is a smart phone the
enemy of boredom it really is because
you know anytime anybody gets up to go
to the bathroom at the dinner table
we're all checking our phones thinking
that there's some great answer happening
there and the person going to the
bathroom usually takes their phone
everybody gets upset waiting online for
them so you're basically saying we
should plan downtime boredom absolutely
yes and you know it's really important
to not have every minute of your day
structured you know bosses don't realize
this they think that like if you can
account for your time than somebody's
magical things are happening and that's
not the case yeah another thing is don't
have as many meetings most people are
checked out like if you want to have an
enemy of productivity scheduling
meetings at length is the way to go for
that unless they're boring meetings yeah
that's a different kind of boredom so
embracing boredom is a good thing yes
and getting addicted you know when
you're talking about smart phones what's
happening is our brain is flooded with
dopamine and then we end up becoming
desensitized needing more and more
stimulation to get us away from that
board yeah your brain doesn't your brain
in that moment isn't really allowed to
wander in the same kind of way whenever
when you're just sort of letting your
mind float exactly it's distracted but
unsatisfied yeah yeah exactly boredom as
well and yeah that's a hard thing for me
yeah work on it dr. sue Varma thank you
very much for being here we appreciate
it